I haven't seen my father in 15 years why  am I not surprised his obsessions are  still getting me in trouble  as a kid I believed my father stories as  an adult I believed his stories were  fantasies Scarlett we all owe your  father a trade yet we will do whatever  it takes to get him back this is magic  dark magic  let's go so it's your show do you have  an explanation for the horrors on  fooling around us these symbols this  vessel  it's all connected I stared into the  abyss and the abyss gave me a gun I  [Applause]  think I'm in love  [Applause]  you know  where are we  it's not a matter of where Diego but  when  don't travel great let's find something  to shoot  [Music]  judith wright your savior is here  started lookout  play the private beta first on ps4  please